راح نتحدث عن كيف ممكن نشتري سياره وكيف
ممكن ندفع ثمنها اي والله كيف ندفع ثمنها
صحيح راويه الحقيقه اليوم السيارات سوقها
صاير نار نار وشراب بكثير من الدول لاسباب
مختلفه منها ارتفاع الضرائب القطاع
التوريدات الشحن حتى ان المعامل الكبيره
اليوم تعاني من ازمات تتعلق بصناعه
السيارات بهذه الصناعه العملاقه اكيد طبعا
شراء السياره مشاهدينا هو فن ممكن انه
كتير ناس ما بيعرفوا عنه الكثير هناك
اوقات وهناك اساليب فضلا عن طريق دفع
معينه يمكن انه يتابعها الاشخاص العازمين
على شراء السيارات سواء راغبوا بالسيارات
الجديده او حتى المستعمله لكن الاهم من كل
هذا نصيحه جوهريه خبراء السيارات يقولونها
دوما للرغبين بالشراء احذر ان يخدعك وكلاء
السيارات
واشتري السياره بعد تفكير ط
ويل
[موسيقى]
طيب بما اني انا مو فنان في شراء السيارات
ولا اعرف اني كيف اشتري سياره ممكن لكن
احنا جايبين فنان بشراء السيارات يمكن
يدفع ثمنها اذا تبين سياره طيب احنا راح
نستضيف ضيفنا نرحب بضيفنا الشريك المؤسس
لمنصه عرب جي تي للسيارات كريم ذيب صباح
الخير صباح الورد
[ضحك]
اليوم اليوم يعني سوق السيارات مرتفع مش
بس السيارات الجديده حتى السيارات
المستعمله كيف نفكر بشراء سياره لمن يحتاج
السيارات وقعدت اكثر من اربعه اشهر بدون
سياره صحيح واشتريت سياره والان ندمان
الندمان لانه ما اخذت السياره اللي انا
بدي اياها او اللي انا ابيه هي هاي
المشكله صارت ارتفاع اسعار السيارات بسبب
الازمه العالميه نقص اشباه الموصلات نقص
المواد الاوليه لصناعه السيارات وفي ضغط
كبير في طلب ولكن ما في عرض فارتفع سوق
السيارات المستعمله عند الناس بشكل عام في
بعض
غليه الاسعار فانا بدل ما اروح انتظر اشهر
عشان استلم السياره اللي احبها خلاص انا
محتاج اخذ سياره ولكن انت كنت فيك تسوي
حركه غير انك تشتري سياره قول كان ممكن
تروح لموضوع تاجير السياره لفتره معينه
بعدين تشتري السياره او ما تاخذ سياره
غاليه بنفس السعر اللي كنت حاطط فيه
السياره اللي تحبها خذ سياره مشي امورك
فيها سياره بسيطه عارف انه انت سعرها
بيمسك في المنطقه عنه او في السوق اوكي
تمشي فيه تستخدمها فتره عبال ما توصل
سيارتك او فكره
التاجيل بانتهاء اللي هو بيصير فيه بعدين
تمليك ايضا فكره جميله يعني
واحد اخد شي ما بحب الحين راح ناخذ شيء
احبه بالضبط
شخص عندي جهل تام واميه فيما يتعلق
بالسيارات انا بالنسبه الي هاي سياره حلوه
شكلها كتير حلو وهي لا هاي لونها حلو يعني
بيتهيا لي هاي نظره النساء شو بتقدر
تعطينا نصائح تبس لاشخاص مثلي ما بيعرفوا
كتير شو يشتروا شو يدوروا على ايش بالضبط
لحتى ايش بك بتعرفي انت ايش محتاجه ليش
بتشتري سياره هل انت عندك عائله ولا انت
لحالك ولا انتو شخصين فقط في السياره انت
شو الطرق اللي بتمشي عليها طرق عاديه ولا
طرق بعيده مرتفعات طرق فيها مطبات فيها
حفر عرفت كيف كم ميزانيتك هل هذه اول
سياره تشتريها شو خبرتك انت لو اخذتي
السياره مستعمله هل حتعرفي تتعاملي مع
الكراجات ليصلحوا سيارتك هل حتى تعرفي قبل
ما تشتريها تفحصيها في مكان صح ما تنغشي
بالسياره المستعمله في مجالك انت او في
حال ما بيعرف السيارات بيشتروا السيارات
الجديده بريح راسه عليها ضمان من الوكاله
والصيانه بالوكاله تمام فبالتالي بتشوفي
انت شو ميزانيتك كم مرات بكلبشتريها كاش
ولاقصه
ادفع من راتبي على السيارات النسبه بعلم
الاموال الاقتصادي الواحد اذا بده يشتري
اي شيء بخصوصا السيارات ما يتجاوز ال15%
من راتبك 15 وهذا هو السعر اللي انت تكلمت
عليه في البدايه انه قد يكون خسارتك
بالسياره الجديده ان اذا في حال ارجاع لكن
اليوم دخل منافس جديد في سوق السيارات
يعني انا ما اشوف السياره الالمانيه او
الامريكيه اروح الى الصينيه وهو الوافد
الجديد الاقي مميزات وسعر ارخص افضل منها
سعر ارخص بس الخوف من النقطه اللي قلتها
اذا اختربت الصيانه شلون اهم نقطه بشراء
اي سياره بالاخر السياره هي شيء مستهلك
وانت بتحتاج الى صيانه اي سياره تشتريها
اذا ما كان في قطع غيار متوفره فانتوقعت
في الفخذ فدائما بحكي للناس في سيارات نحن
بنحبها نحب نشتريها ولكن يا اخي قطع
الغيار غير متوفره بشكل كبير فهذا الشيء
بيؤدي انت حتخسر ليش حتوقف سيارتك لفتره
طويله وهذا كثير من الصناعه الصينين عم
يواجهوك ووكالات محليه قبل
ما في حاله الكاش اذا كان واحد مقتدر هو
مو بحاجه لمبلغ الكاش للاستثمار ممكن شراء
السياره لو بالشراء الكاش بتريح انت من
الفوائد في ناس ما بتحب البنوك والفوائد
من ناحيه حلال وحرام هذا مجال مختلف اما
بالنسبه ايضا من ناحيه الكاش انت بتخلص
موضوع انه يلزموك بتامين معين ولكن حريه
والبيع والشراء مثل ما بدك والتجديد ننتظر
العروض ولا ولا العروض دائما موجوده
وموجوده في سيارات على حسب الموسم طيب
سيارات المكشوفه في الخليج
طيب وخليها بتركبها بالشتاء كريم ديب شكرا
جزيلا لك شكرا
يعطيك الف عافيه الله يعافيك يا رب شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد نبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات